NOAM WOLF: So welcome
everyone.
Thank you so much for
joining my session.
My name--
I see a couple people still
walking in, so we'll wait like
a few more seconds.
Guy on the phone.
All right.
So my name's Noam Wolf, I'm a
tech lead manager on Google's
Ad Exchange.
I've been at Google for about
seven years now exclusively
working on ads.
And I'm really excited to tell
you about something my team
and I've been working on
for the past year.
But first, I'd like to take you
through a quick overview
and the history of display
advertising.
Before I do that, I want
to get an idea of
who my audience is.
So who here knows what display
advertising is?
Just a show of hand.
Oh wow.
Maybe I can skip all
of my slides.
All right, I wasn't
expecting that.
So I'll do this pretty
quickly.
Display advertising is generally
considered anything
that is of image format for
online advertising.
Now image form could mean rich
media, images, video.
We categorize mobile
in there, as well.
But we exclude search
ads, AKA text ads.
Even though Wikipedia doesn't
make that distinction.
But not everything on
Wikipedia is true.
So leading up to 2008, display
advertising was
a very manual process.
If anybody here had to do
display advertising before
2008, you know what
I'm talking about.
Advertisers, these are the
people that want to sell
something or have their brand
out there, would reach out to
these websites, what we call
publishers, and say, hey, I'd
like to advertise on your space,
on your inventory.
And the publisher
would say, cool.
That will cost you x dollars for
every 1,000 impressions.
An impression is--
as by show of your hands before,
everybody knows--
is when I load a website, I see
an ad, we count that as
one impression.
So the prices were fixed.
And the what and the when of
my ads, like when were they
going to show, who were they
going to show to, were all
predetermined.
So it's all done offline.
2008 was--
well, maybe I'm only
that calls this--
the year of the exchanges.
Right Media had an exchange.
DoubleClick had an exchange.
And AdECN had an exchange,
and maybe there
were some small ones.
And these were platforms that
enabled bidded buying of
online advertising.
Now the bidded part is the
interesting part, because this
is where we went from fixed
pricing to dynamic pricing.
We ran second price auctions.
This is a little different
than Google AdWords
generalized second price
auction, because you really
only have one winner because
you're going
for one ad at a time.
And advertisers would
still have to
preload their campaigns.
They would have to basically
tell us what they want to
show, who they want
to show it to.
So all their targeting was done
through a web UI, still
the same thing.
They'd actually have to upload
their ad, what we call
creative, into our system.
And at serving time, we would
decide which ad won based on
the bid that they associated
with that ad.
So a bid from the advertiser's
side would say, here is the
max amount of money that I'd
like to pay for showing this
ad on your website.
And the publisher, the website
would say, here is the minimum
amount of money I'm willing
to receive.
So the exchange orchestrated all
that, basically making it
a platform.
Ad networks, which I'm
guessing some of you
represent, would aggregate
advertisers.
So they would represent multiple
advertisers and bid
on their behalf.
Ad exchanges really introduced
more transparency, because of
the fixed pricing, in
their reporting.
Something that ad networks, at
that time, didn't really do.
So fast-forward to 2010, RTB.
RTB was invented, Real-Time
Bidding.
Real-time bidding
was a way to do
per-impression decision making.
Now I want you to really think
about that for a second.
For every impression, you're
going to make a decision.
You're going to make a decision
of how much you want
to pay, if you want to pay,
maybe you don't want this
impression, and you're going to
pass the creative, the ad
that you want to show to
the customer, to the
user, in real time.
So it's not really a
protocol, right?
But every exchange has a very
similar set of details, of
attributes, of metadata, that
they pass on the server side
to your bidders.
These bidders, these are the
pieces of software that are
very, very nontrivial pieces of
code, need to be scalable,
need to be available, because
of two very, very strict
constraints in RTB.
These constraints are one,
exchanges typically require
100 milliseconds for you to
respond to this bid request.
So the page will load, the
tag, we'll call the ad
exchange, ad exchange will make
a server side call to the
partners, to whoever is eligible
to receive that call,
these are the bidders.
And the bidders are required
to respond within 100
milliseconds.
Now that's very difficult.
So that's one constraint.
Constraint number
two, is scale.
Right?
Exchanges tend to
be a bit chatty.
And they also throttle
without mercy.
So if you don't respond to at
least 85% of these requests,
then you're going
to be throttled.
And you're going to miss on
the impressions that you
really want to get.
So scale is a big deal here.
And it's very big scale.
This is the key node in every
other session says Google
scale, well RTB is probably
the biggest
QPS in all of Google.
So we're talking about hundreds
of thousands of
queries per second.
And you have to make a decision
per second for each
one of these impressions.
Did anybody just blink?
Martin did.
Well, that took him
300 milliseconds.
300 milliseconds to blink.
200 milliseconds to recognize
facial expressions.
So just to give you an idea of
what 100 milliseconds is,
there's some cool facts about
Ferraris and stuff up on the
slide, but I'm not going to
go into too much detail.
But this gives you an idea
of how much you have
to do in that time.
So why do I want to do RTB?
Well, display is a $40
billion market.
If it wasn't a $40 billion
market, in the context of
Google I/O, you probably
wouldn't be in this room.
And display is growing
immensely.
59% of that business is going to
be attributed to RTB, which
is growing faster than your
static buying, which is
non-RTB, it's non-real-time,
if you will.
And RTB, in 2012 alone,
accounted
for almost $2 billion.
So we know what display
advertising is.
I think we reached
that conclusion
very, very early on.
We know what exchanges are.
We know what bidders
are now and how
difficult they are to build.
And I think I met a couple of
you who said that they want to
build bidders, but they're
not sure where to start.
And we know why we want
to build them.
It's a very lucrative market.
So what are my options?
How can I participate in RTB?
Well, today you have
two options.
Option one, you build
it yourself.
Hire an engineering team.
You build out a data center.
You figure out optimization
algorithms.
And to scale, you throw
money at the problem.
And this gives you a
lot of flexibility.
You could do whatever
you want.
You could really take advantage
of every single
attribute in that protocol
I just talked about.
You could do whatever
you want with it
because it's your bidder.
But you have to scale
very, very quickly.
And scaling in regular data
centers is really, really hard
and costly.
So two resources.
Engineering and machines.
That's not something that
everybody can just afford.
Option number two, you hire
somebody to do it for you.
You go to DSP, a demand
site platform,
that has a data center.
They have an engineering team.
They have optimization modules
for you to use.
And you still pay
them to do it.
You probably pay less than
building out a data center.
And they help you scale.
But the downside is you don't
get that flexibility.
You kind of get a black
box solution.
Oh, you optimize for me?
Great.
Can I change?
No.
But what about-- no.
Right?
So I'm really, really excited
to tell you about a third
option today.
And this is the Open Bidder.
Open Bidder is a fully
customizable toolkit that
enables bidded buying
on the exchange.
It lets you manage your
real-time virtual machines.
And if any of you attended
Navneet and Martin's talk
yesterday, you got a little
bit of a demo of how fast
virtual machines start
up in GCE.
So GCE, Google Compute Engine,
which have a pretty dominant
set of talks at I/O, and I urge
you to see the ones that
are still left to see.
They really talk about how
GCE is really good.
The reason that we even
integrate with GCE is because--
and I pull this out of their
deck on the next slide--
is that during peak
hours, GCE will
provide 20% lower latency.
Now I can probably repeat all
the stuff that Navneet said,
but one thing that really,
really caught my attention was
the per-minute pricing, as
opposed to competitors where
you have to pay per hour.
Now think about 100,000
impressions requests per
second, right?
If you're only responding 10
minutes out of the whole hour,
you still get a lot in, and you
don't have to pay for the
whole hour.
So GCE really provides a huge
value in this context.
The latency for bidders
is a huge deal, as
we mentioned before.
And we really want to lower
the bar of entry.
So we want to give you back as
much of that 100 milliseconds
as we possibly can.
So instead of spending 40 to,
worst case, 80 milliseconds
just in network traffic, we
want to minimize that.
Ideally, sub five milliseconds,
but I can't
quote numbers just now.
We want you to focus
on cool innovation.
We want you to innovate
in RTB.
Something that I didn't prepare
for in these slides
and I'm really happy to share
with you is somebody walked up
to us at the booth today, and
he said, why doesn't Google
sue all the ad blockers?
I was like, all right, let's
see what this guy wants.
I said, well, ad blockers,
it's a business.
People don't want to see ads.
Our responsibility as
advertisers is to show the
right ad to the right user
at the right time.
However, we're kind
of restricted with
the players out there.
We either use a solution that
exists, or we build something
from scratch, and we
spend a lot of time
and money doing it.
So I really believe that this
toolkit, one of you guys, my
fellow colleague developers,
could go out and build
something that will be better
or fairer than ad blockers.
Because this guy's thing was,
well it's not fair.
It's theft.
You're stealing the money from
the publisher because they're
not showing ads, so they're
not getting paid.
And I said, that's
a good point.
So you're a publisher?
He's like, no, I write
ad blockers.
[LAUGHTER]
NOAM WOLF: That was really
not prepared.
That really happened today.
Anyway, I'd like to walk you
through the life of a bid
request real quick, in the
context of Open Bidder.
The red outline is Google
Compute Engine, where our
virtual machines run Open
Bidder's servers.
We'll use the DoubleClick Ad
Exchange by Google as an
example of an exchange, sending
an exchange-specific
bid request into Open Bidder.
Open Bidder receives this
request and translates it into
a normalized protobuffer
internal to Open Bidder.
This is pretty nice.
It lets you be flexible to
support other exchanges.
We don't want to be only tied
to DoubleClick exchange.
This will be an open
source tool kit.
And you get to run through
the stack of what we call
interceptors, and I'll talk
in detail about those
interceptors in a few
seconds, where you
run your custom logic.
So remember before, I said, we
want you to focus on your
custom logic.
This is the piece
that you write.
This is your secret sauce.
So you run through the
stack with the Open
Bidder specific proto.
And then you run back up the
pipe with a response.
We have a lifecycle.
You could do pre-processing,
you can do post-processing,
and I'll talk about
that in a second.
And the bid is then sent back
to the exchange, all within
100 milliseconds.
So let's go out, let's
take a step back
and look at the ecosystem.
So the ecosystem's been plugged
for GCE in every
single session.
And we're actually using
all these things.
And I thought it would be cool
to put everything together to
kind of a real business
on GCE.
So cloud storage, you get your
persistent disc, you get it
stickied to your sessions,
to your virtual machines.
We use that in the core of
Open Bidder to store
metadata, et cetera.
I think the sample app that Joe
wrote, if you were at the
GCE tech session, they
actually passed
the go code as metadata.
Which I thought was pretty
cool and smart.
Google BigQuery will let you
analyze the data in your logs,
basically whatever you want.
But in this case, what
you're interested
in is in logs, right?
What did I bid?
How much did bid?
How much did I end up
paying when I won?
It's a second price auction.
So what you bid isn't
necessarily what
you're going to pay.
And we have a Prediction API,
which I personally think is
really, really cool, especially
from a computer
science point of view.
You get to train your models.
You can do this with train
requests, and you could do
that asynchronously.
It shouldn't affect your
100 milliseconds.
But you can also request a
prediction in real time.
There's one more thing that
I left out, which is you.
I think this could be a very
nice community for you guys to
add value to this space.
If you think you can do better
than Prediction API that
Google provides, then you
should go out and do it.
And you should use our
APIs to plug-in and
charge for a service.
You're going to be hosted on
the same network inside
Google, and everybody's going
to benefit from this.
We talked about locating your
virtual machines within
Google, this lowers
your latency.
And we talked about scale.
You can start instances
up very, very
quickly as the demo showed.
And you have all these
value-add services.
So one thing I didn't mention
is App Engine.
Currently, we use App Engine to
configure our virtual machines.
We have a configuration UI.
You can start and stop your
virtual machines, you can see
your resources, what
your state is.
We have plans to move that to
a more hosted environment.
But we can keep that around, and
we want to hear from you
if this is something that's
useful to you.
BigQuery, I want to plug it
again because there's a talk
right after this that has a
demo for BigQuery about
crunching terabytes of data.
And you get really cool
visualizations, so if you want
to stick around after this for
the next session, they'll talk
about BigQuery.
So we know that all of you kind
of raised your hands when
I asked if you know what display
advertising was.
Who here is a developer?
All right, sweet.
Who wants to see some code?
All right.
But before that, just a few
features of Open Bidder that
are really important as
part of the stack.
Obviously, we support bidding
because we're a bidder.
And we support click and
impression callbacks.
Right?
So you want the impression.
Well, how do you know
that you want it?
So a lot of these exchanges have
macros that allow you to
set up callbacks and fill those
macros in with a winning
bid price, for example.
So then you can use that
to log and do your own
optimizations.
Cookie matching, I'm sure
everybody knows what that is
for remarketing.
We also support that
out of the box.
So here's some code.
I promised our interceptor
model, which is heavily based
on the Java Filter API, so if
you know or have used the Java
Filter API, none of this should
be earth-shattering.
But at the core of Open
Bidder, we have two
interfaces.
We have an interceptor
chain, which is
responsible for the lifecycle.
You have access to the bid
request and the bid response
and you can chain these
interceptors.
And then you have interceptor
API, not surprising, and it
has an execute method.
So each one of these
interceptors when implemented,
you can get executed
by the workflow.
And you can, like I said before,
do pre-processing and
post-processing steps.
So here's a sample
interceptor.
It's my secret sauce
And, not surprising, it extends
a bid interceptor, and
through the execute method you
get access to the chain.
And notice just at the very
bottom, I call chain.proceed,
so anything before that is
going down the stack.
So I go interceptor by
interceptor by interceptor
going down.
Any work that I do after
chain.proceed is on
the way back up.
And this is really cool for
logging, if you want to have
access to decisions that other
interceptors made.
So this interceptor basically
grabs the requests, asks for
the pre-targeted ad units--
these are ad units from
DoubleClick's ad exchange that
you've set for pre-targeting
through AdWords UI, or the Ad
Exchange UI, and you build
these new snippets.
What price you should
charge for them?
Well, that's your
secret sauce.
Highlighted in bold.
Favorite quote of mine, or one
of the favorite quotes that I
have, from one of our beta
testers, and we've actually
been beta testing for a while
now, is that they really love
the flexibility of what we've
provided, and they've seen
some results that they really
want to move their spend over
to Open Bidder.
I saw some smiles here.
I don't know if you're the
client, but I won't out you.
So I'd like to wrap up
with a little bit
of a product vision.
Where are we going?
Where do we see ourselves
in a year from now?
And our product vision really
circles around three main
categories.
The first category is additional
components.
We have a dedicated team.
They're actually sitting up
front here, and I'll introduce
them in a second.
And we are fully dedicated to
this open source toolkit.
So we keep adding more value, we
keep listening to feedback,
and we keep enhancing
our offering.
We gather feedback, either
through a forum, we're
probably going to be on Stack
Exchange when we open this up,
and we look to hear for
feedback, as much feedback as
you can possibly give us.
The beta testers will attest
to the fact that we're very
responsive.
More GCE.
So you heard about a new load
balancing service from GCE.
We're kind of at the forefront
of the new GCE stuff.
GCE stuff comes out, we test
it for them at our scale.
And so you're immediately
going to get that.
And I think that's a really,
really cool feature.
And then the last, but
absolutely not least.
My personal favorite part of
Open Bidder is the community.
So we will open source this
after we're out of beta.
We want to see the community
give back and grow because I
really believe that Open Bidder
is the platform for RTB
innovation.
And we can get rid of stuff like
ad blockers with a much
smarter solution, which I'm sure
many of you are thinking
about right now or already
know the solution for.
And there's no reason why you
can't you monetize that and
save the web at the same time.
So I want to leave you with one
very last quote from our
friends at TwelveFold that saw
this when we pitched it to
them, it was like 14 months ago,
and they said, you know,
there's a huge gap
in the bidder
landscape for custom logic.
Open Bidder, which was actually
a different name back
then, is a brilliant idea.
Where do I sign up?
Well, today you can sign up
for our beta process.
Our documentation, as you can
see at the bottom, is open
source now.
So you can go there right now.
See what we have in store for
you, what we can do, our
capabilities.
And when you sign up, we can
white-list you for our code.
I also have the QR code
in the corner, that's
actually not the code.
It's actually rating
the session.
So you can either scan this, I'd
be very happy to hear any
feedback about this
specific session.
What you want to see
more of, et cetera.
And there's also a QR
code in the back.
And I think that's about it.
I'd like to spend the next maybe
10 minutes to answer
some questions, if you have.
And I'd like to call
up the team.
So we have William Shields, our
tech lead, [? Jiannan ?]
[? Wang ?], our UI guru,
and [? Risvaldo ?]
[INAUDIBLE].
I can't pronounce
his last name.
The back end lead.
So come on up, and
let's see if we
can answer some questions.
Or should I ask if you have
any questions first?
[APPLAUSE]
NOAM WOLF: Thank you.
Perfect, thank you.
Sure.
I think this is being
recorded.
AUDIENCE 1: Hi.
So it is the bidder agnostic to
what kind of inventory it's
going to bid for?
So if it's mobile apps, or
mobile web, or display web,
does it make a distinction?
Or is it completely
agnostic to that?
NOAM WOLF: So the bidder
is a platform.
We're worried about
infrastructure.
The logic of what to bid
for and what you're
eligible for is on you.
You have access to the proto,
to the request.
So you can basically see if it's
mobile, if it's video and
whatnot, depending on
those attributes.
AUDIENCE 2: Hey guys, what
cookie space do you support?
Would we have our own pixels
that we would map to?
Or could we leverage
DoubleClick?
WILLIAM SHIELDS: Well, we
support out of the box, the
DoubleClick cookie matching.
So that probably has the most
value from what you're looking
at, which is to match
DoubleClick cookie space.
AUDIENCE 2: And do you
support OpenRTB?
WILLIAM SHIELDS: I can neither
confirm nor deny our
particular status
with open RTB.
We've thought a lot about
the problem of
cross-exchange buying.
This is still actually a work
in progress, so we've got
nothing concrete to announce on
this particular regard, but
it's certainly something we've
been thinking about.
NOAM WOLF: Any other
questions?
All right, well thank you very
much for coming out, and we
look to see you innovating
RTB.
[APPLAUSE]